hey texas new york philadelphia take the
jolly ranchers out of your ears and
listen up because the keep it moving
tour is coming your way yeah guys uh
it's a stand-up show when we play ayg
with the audience it's a good time uh
september 21st will be in san antonio
september 22nd we're going to be in
houston and september 23rd to the 25th
we're going to be in austin for the moon
tower comedy festival ever heard of it
then uh dallas fort worth on september
26th then we're bringing it back up
north baby uh september 30th we're going
to be in long island
and then
what are we doing if we're going home
for cheese steaks
whiz wit baby october cheesesteaks and
vengeance october 27th we're gonna be at
helium comedy club in philadelphia get
those tickets they're gonna move fast
i'm telling you yeah do it yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find that if they go to be classy yeah
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash that's right i'm your host holy
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at aunt toddy's basement yeah
there's one word on her mind it's eagles
eagles excited she's trying out
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me you get to laugh and you get
out kids that's two in a row
that's two in a row you got me
ladies and gentlemen he is the ceo of ru
garbage he is an international
businessman and i'll tell you this right
now he is not to be trifled with in a
board room south of dusseldorf
give it up for kevin james ryan hey gang
happy to be here i got to give you that
one got me big man
someone said in the last sweet
that's exactly it that's exactly a stick
to move baby keep them quick
these tick tockers don't got a [ __ ]
attention span you know what i mean
i got to adjust my range somebody in the
comments because they can't be just
laughing an antiquity joke
uh what's up gang and thanks for tuning
in as always please make sure you
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube but as you know those numbers
are true the roof true the [ __ ] roof
just hit 25 000 over there on youtube
and then i would be remissed an [ __ ]
a jerk off if i didn't bring up the
greatest website in the history of man
shout out to al gore for inventing the
[ __ ] internet
patreon.com ru garbage that's cooking
amen sign up there you go bonus episodes
of ayg episodes of hard feelings which
is a completely different podcast uh
just me and foley chopping it up a
little bit behind the scenes a little
bit of hr oh yeah uh
house cleaning and then live streams uh
we do monthly with our top tier guests
get some [ __ ] merch there's a couple
of beer koozies left and a couple of
card games left and then come see a
[ __ ] live show yeah come see your
show and having a nice shout out to our
producer extraordinaire he's the magic
man makes us all look good who's that
give it up for the astoria kid t-bone
mcmuffin
toby mcmahon what's up dudes what up
t-bone dude i'm just giggling thinking
about invincible with [ __ ] ant
she's lining up in the slot with a new
port and a house dress that's exactly
what i i pictured her getting [ __ ]
hung out to dry across the middle
in a housecoat when i hit the slant you
hit me she's lighting another one with
her
old sick gang we could not be more
excited to have our incredibly special
guest back with us again today one of
our absolutely favorite episodes you
have to check him out he's uh super
funny super amazing we love him and he
has an amazing new podcast called friday
night greg do me a favor give it up for
the one the only
mr greg stone
ladies and gentlemen god bless
these guys about to be a new daddy oh
very soon coming soon me moving to
mexico
[Laughter]
i'll be on the beach having a good time
would you ever split town would you
bounce
ah like the fun ideas yes
right we're having fun here i freak i
bounce i never see this kid again i got
a mustache i cut my eye where an eye
patch do that but reality is man i i
want to be a dad i'm so excited that's
awesome
you're one of the best guys ever and
you're going to be a fantastic dad my
[ __ ] dad you guys every comedian i
know i'm like how you doing you're doing
all right yeah he does you real hard
he's good which is it's endearing he
showed up with gi joe's for foley yeah
sorry he missed your birthday kid he did
good on his report a little something
you have no idea the the the uh
endorphins this triggers just when i see
these things yeah yeah
it's bad though because i'm you know i'm
such an action figure guy
i mean you're you're bonko's i'm not
going that right that's what i have a
couple of guys to play with when i got
an eddie or two and me you know what i
mean what i said that's what we all say
we go i just want one to put around is a
thing next thing you know what you are
fighting people in the backstock of a
target going i know they're in here
somewhere
i street date my ass you're looking for
a shredder
in the middle of a [ __ ] bunch of
toasters where are the turtles man where
are the turtles
yeah
i do think about that though as far as
dads and stuff like that the bilbert
joke is so is so perfect when he's like
i know guys would have left by now
because i think about my dad when we
were kid [ __ ] that being my brother like
driving them both insane yeah on like a
sunday like totally responsible for it
any punishment we got we're deserving of
it and like my dad just you could tell
just wanting to be like [ __ ] my god
what am i doing yeah he's pulled out of
the driveway a couple of times too
but then he comes back like an hour
later
yeah my step-dad like he's a step-dad
you know he came in
like what's this guy's commitment to my
wife it's like my my to my mom or
whatever my real dad though was like you
know he showed up on the weekends i'm
like hey doing danny's like we're going
to the bronx zoo and he was the best you
know got all the questions
rock and roll my mom meanwhile rick's
taking the brunt into here
he's doing the homework and [ __ ] yeah
yeah george was myself that george was
like a psycho he was a cop he uh dude
it's like is he still in the picture
yeah okay he's a maniac because he's
still you were saying was i wasn't sure
of what happened he still have a job as
the question we don't need the newark
heat coming down on us
now he like he doesn't really talk uh he
says the only things he says is like
he'll do jaws quotes
uh this guy get this guy a couple of
deacons sport of god you're just like
hey doing george you go think we're
gonna need a bigger boat and you're like
okay man like he's kind of like force
gumpy man it's up to game on will you
he never says anything about emotions
this year for the first time we were
leaving and uh he just go he'll just say
like i am he says i am groot now he saw
guardians of galaxy loved it so he sees
i am groot and a few yeah no go ahead i
think get in there get in there
is he legally allowed to be married i
don't think so yeah yeah he's very we
say foreign yeah my dad pulling out of
the driveway
never in my life did he ever say
anything
like i'm proud of you or i love you
recently we're sitting in the car he
goes see you later
we are groot and i just started bawling
i just like this is how he says i love
you this is how george says i love you
he said we are groot maybe my wife are
dying i'm crying she's laughing i'm like
he's never said it yeah yeah yeah the
two high school football players showed
up and beat you both up
he got he has a reel of mice and men
yeah
makes guns my step-dad in the basement i
remember you telling us about this on
the app yeah oh i did i believe so yeah
no no no no no no
oh that's a good piece of paper
i didn't mean to shut it down i'm just
trying to connect with you you're psycho
no you're like oh what i did i'm sorry
you know i got podcast bits you know i
come in i go i do this
story i plug my patreon and then get the
[ __ ] out of there by the way plug the
patreon right now plug it up greg
stonezone it's uh my patreon the greg
stone zone check it out greg is so
[ __ ] funny yeah if you like uh
watching a guy high out of his mind
uh saying a bunch of things and whatever
it's fun we do music we have music on
the intuos it's fantastic guys go go
check out his patreon it's awesome 100
oh thanks boys
um that's so funny is that it we had gas
i had a fun time yeah that's great this
guy keeps you on your [ __ ] toes i
gotta i gotta be honest with you just
took a breath
we did zero to a hundred for the first
four minutes
all right let me blink for a second
i'm gonna sip ice coffee like a
gentleman
you got to hit him and run baby
oh god that's george looking into the
conversation right there
he's good talking to him just can't have
a beat in the conversation oh that's so
funny yeah gang this is a family episode
so as you know when you started
you really did just hard reset that
well it's uh 12 22 and the weather is
looking a little rainy out there
back to you rick
crazy guy greg stone's in the studio
and we're back
greg so we heard that you had a crazy
time in a raincoat recently well i gotta
tell you i was out in the rain
and uh where am i gonna put my monkeys i
put them in the coat now i'm in a coffee
shop monkeys are everywhere
anyway man back to you rick
[Laughter]
oh buddy we got a hot one already folks
somebody call the exterminator we got
some giggles in here
why are you killing giggles yeah all
right why do you want to get in there
murdering giggles
[ __ ] fun stopper over here all right
let's get to some [ __ ] questions here
yeah but as we just said earlier it is
uh
i don't know yes whatever it is a family
episode uh with a little company a
little company that's right it's a
family episode
i got corporate all over i'm gonna have
to [ __ ] break out the flow chart for
this one um we have a we have a little
bit of company so we're going to answer
your patreon questions as you know when
you sign up for the patreon we'll answer
your question on the air
uh and we got some [ __ ] heaters and
we're going to get to everybody there's
a backlog uh we will get to everybody i
promise uh it's just uh we gotta you
know not every question is right for
every guest by the way hundred percent
you know i gotta i gotta tailor them a
little bit yeah your next question is
what's it like growing up black if you
were
yeah i guess i gotta get this one huh
yeah
well some people like you ever shoot
your pants at second grade and then
sally makes money and you got a huge
crush on her and then you can't get a
boner ever again i'm like that's a
little too specific guys
i sent that one in
um all right this one's from tory uh
this is a home run uh right off the bat
have you ever eaten in a pool oh yes yes
yes of course have i ever not eaten a
pool i always eat in a pool and i'm
always surrounded with crumbs and
nibblings around my body i get out of
the pool and you see the line the top of
the pool from the muffin that is just on
my body top five whole foods got to be
hot dogs pizza oh right what else
well i like candy i think you can't be
doing like pasta or anything
you can't be doing i can't have a nice
you ever had fried diablo in the shallow
end of a public pool i do clams i like
clams casino
uh
just up to the neck in water oh dude
yeah i like to go to like a casino and
get real stone when i'm like we're
performing in casinos
i get a real stoned i bring in whatever
they got in the buffet and i just bring
it right to you take it to the pool yeah
we're talking outdoor pools dude you're
eating in an indoor pool with that
chlorine smell yes
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] next level yeah man trash
or
it's called see you when you say trash i
say uh
compress what is it when you're putting
more than one things into one thing at a
time compounding multitasking
multitasking i'm eating i'm enjoying i'm
ruining everybody else's day at the pool
jesus christ yeah of course i like a
coke can of coke and then the pool water
goes in there and you can taste a little
bit oh that happens with beers when
you're doing yeah all right yeah yeah
stick the top off i've definitely drank
some river or some lake
doritos will never taste better than
when chlorine is oh dude i hate that
with [ __ ] chips and stuff like that
are around the pool too much it's soggy
real quick yeah yeah yeah yeah fail nah
yeah oh man candy's acceptable
is crazy candy in a pool candy is one
second i'm not were
[Laughter]
why has it got to be a werther's
that's just what he pulled and it was
funny
reese's peanut butter cup you're doing a
chocolate so good chocolate chocolate
chocolate's no good
where are you from minnesota i don't
know this guy's coming in
this kid's birthday this is we got the
old brew
that's just pure vodka
it's bailey's on the rocks i'm doing dmt
and coffee
uh yeah candies
stop stop stop back it up
there's a rapper involved that's no good
ice cream truck pulls up the ice cream
truck has the ch has he's not pulling up
to the pool yeah the indoor pool
smashes through the window listen i'm
not buying the indoor pool i assume this
question meant for an outdoor public
pool
without a snack bar and access to an ice
cream truck i understood it maybe that's
as well
never once did i think about an indoor
pool that's crazy i also need to just
state that there is no access
is your pool in the front of your house
you know there's no access to the ice
cream truck from the backyard you hear
the thing you run outside like a
gentleman outside
my point with the ice cream truck was
the guy has ice cream treats but then
they also always had a few candies too
right they had some now and laters they
had some fun dips they had some [ __ ]
blow pops and stuff like that so
knocking back a [ __ ] fun dip in the
shallow end of the kiddie pool i think
that's a gentleman's move in a hot
summer day no i also i think i think a
pry i think your your own pool's okay
not buffet items at an indoor pool ain't
candy chewing gum i'll draw the line
there
that's too much i think you got to get
that like uh what's that that sugar you
know the the one that's all sugar the
pixie stick
will you dip with the candies fun dip
yes
you dump all the fun dip in the pool
turn the pool into a full iced tea
that's pretty good you know just get a
world functional happier like a willy
wonka in your pool you know turn it into
the iced tea pool i don't hate it that's
funny
chlorine no that's 4c that's also that's
also a good idea uh to play a trick on
somebody you know they always said that
the if you if you pee in the pool it'll
turn blue mm-hmm if you had some blue
fondant yeah set your boy up sneak
behind him like oh this guy [ __ ]
pissed me
everyone's sticking
i can't not peanut i i pee in every pool
i go in sorry if i've been at your house
uh
and every time before i pee i'm worried
that's going to happen i could be at a
resort i could be at a that's because
they got us we listened to that [ __ ]
when we were kids that [ __ ] got not real
yeah it's a couple of things that got in
our heads when we were kids santa claus
santa claus the kidnappings got us
because we were we were a kidnapping age
funny you should bring that up i was
actually kidnapped hilarious story uh
some guy kept me in his backyard
hilarious story in his basement for a
few months i didn't see the light of day
and the real knee slapper just remember
the cop reaching in with the light and
being like my god i'm saved anyway back
to you
what other question did you have for me
that's good holy [ __ ]
um great question um all right this
one's from brendan norris ever bought
shoes at a thrift store
or have you bought clothes at a thrift
store 100
100 clothes i did buy sneakers and it's
it's yeah was it a buffalo exchange it
was a buffalo exchange which i give a
little bit of i'd say it's got a little
bit of a little bit of attach shaking if
you don't have a buffalo exchange around
you it's like a thrift store but people
trade in there it's
stuff right it's not like donated i
think i think they bought do they they
buy it it's not mcdonald's it's shake
shack it's like a big step up yes
they'll give you four bucks for your
t-shirt then turn around and sell it for
22. they are they are the i don't know
if this reference is gonna hit they are
the funko land was it funk uh funkel or
uh they are the gamestop of clothing
yeah where you bring a ps5 and they go
you get three i'll give you three
nickels sure and a buffon sure how about
that and you'll you should be happy you
should be happy you piece of [ __ ] why'd
you come in here you bring them an
armani suit they go we'll give you three
dollar store credit a dollar and a half
and a japanese yeah yeah the shoes are
tough and even we all agree i'm
disgusting correct i think you're pretty
good i do i do pretty disgusting things
but the feeling of putting your foot in
a shoe that already has somebody else's
like worn feet in it like where it's got
the ridge in it it's got the ring
someone else's ridge yeah where it's
like it's like somebody else's
mouthpiece like it's [ __ ] molded to
this yeah i've done that with my
oh dude you felt like a mad scientist
you're boiling that oil in water yeah
get it in there good yeah i can't do
that with shoes
no well the trick i believe is what i do
is give them cobbles new insoles no i
just have
the worst feet on the planet okay so i
know whatever i'm going into
is way it's i'm like a kid from vietnam
sure i'll take whatever south jersey
yeah it's like yeah i know you think
this is bad but you should see where i'm
from yeah exactly what i mean it's
cleaning over there yeah yeah yeah so i
don't make sense that's a pretty good
theory yeah yeah yeah i've had athlete's
foot since i was three oh man i had it i
remember having it as like a
seven-year-old yeah yeah no continually
yeah here's the difference
now i don't know if you guys have the
same have the same feeling but i used to
hate it when i was a kid had it really
bad now as an older man when i have just
a little bit mm-hmm oh it's good get
that good itch going that good scratch i
have a foot i have a foot fork that i
use i'm going to [ __ ] throw up greg
why a foot fork yeah it's a special i
don't use that's we don't want an actual
fork or is it a tool called no no it's a
force it's your feet and shrimp
scratches
no it's a [ __ ] fork it is yeah it's a
fork for scratching my feet that will
not be put back into rotation for eating
where do you keep it in my nightstand by
my bed that is and i haven't just made
my skin crawl oh it's good
it works through the it works through
the through the sock that's how good it
is sometimes through the sockets it
gives you that extra roughness it's nice
i like i like scratching a barefoot with
the sock on the on the other foot oh
sandpaper
but i want to feel rich
[Laughter]
no idea how bad my feet were i had there
was a there was a show called are you
not using ten acting or nothing like
that it's not actually stuff acting it's
not actually think what i have is i have
some weird allergy my feet are like
allergic to my sweat so it's this
constant like battle of he's got
off-brand athlete's foot
[Laughter]
dude i see i saw a doctor and she went
[Laughter]
i took my shoe off and my doctor went in
case a walking toe damn that stunk
until we make that lap toby make that
louder
can you cut the last three seconds
can we go back
put it in your toes about athlete's foot
and we're back this crazy thing i have
this crazy foot thing that gets so bad i
would wrap my sock like a towel like
you're gonna whip it put it in between
the toes and just like like uh like he's
cutting down a red bullet yeah exactly
he's got two guys
he's in black and white for some reason
yeah holy [ __ ] if i saw a doctor we're
good now but it was bad for about 12
years wow 12 years about 12 years insane
what's the treatment what kind of cream
oh it's uh or is it a pill that sounds
more like if it's a pill you're in bad
shape it was a pill at first holy they
got a fight they got to fight it from
the end weren't they giving people pills
for like fungus on their toes for a
little while yeah and then they they
stopped that [ __ ] right because it was
like knocking people off left and right
the anti-fungal pill wasn't that like
[ __ ] killing people i don't know i i
didn't have a i didn't have i didn't
have the fungus it was like a whack it
was a way like when you say fungus i'm
like please please i was that's this
is insane yeah yeah they have the show
called the night of with uh tuturo yes
yes do you remember that guy's sweat
thing that's what you had what i got
that they based a show on my foot thing
when i saw that i felt represented
disgusting
for the good guys
these are my people they got my letters
and his name was detective stone or
something like that in the movie the
guy's name was stone in it now it's like
someone has been listening to my podcast
yeah damn hold on you don't have it that
bad though because that was it was worse
you're joking now it's good but it was
the point that people would look at me
and they would go we think you have a
like this diabetes like what is going on
jesus it was really bad i didn't have
health insurance it got better when i
got married i married my wife and got
health insurance okay what was she
saying about the foot issue she would
close her eyes and cry she was fine she
would like my foot would touch her body
and she'd freak and then i would go i'm
sorry it's like no no it's okay i have
to get used to it
it's like kidding you see like a rabid
dog in the house just don't look at him
don't look at him bad dude it was a
nightmare kippy let's talk about the
folks over there at helix mattress i
know you're a fan because you sleep on
one every night and the cool part about
helix you don't just go to a showroom
and look at a mattress and lay on the
same mattress that a million people have
been laying on you take a little quiz
online they determine what kind of
mattress is best for you
do you sleep hot do you sleep cold are
you a big boy do you need a bigger
mattress plus size they got everybody
covered you answer the quiz they match
you with the mattress easy peasy skippy
straighten them out
[Laughter]
talk to these people will you give the
good folks over there at helix uh they
sent me me and my wife up what what a
mattress on a cuff because they're
gentlemen over there and ladies they
know how to take care of it they do they
hooked us up with one of the cuffs that
said listen you try it you let us know
what you like you tell us we took the we
took the quiz it's like two minutes if
that it depends how quick you click two
minutes they set us up we're on the
twilight model and i gotta tell you it's
something else i never had a mattress
that was for me all mine were like oh
there's you know uncle steve's getting
rid of this one sure aunt sally's
getting whatever you found in the
junkyard that's what you're taking this
is my first big boy adult mattress as a
husband and a wife we got and i gotta
tell you it's lights out and when you're
making a purchase like that you wanna
make sure you get the right fit yeah so
why not line yourself up with what's
gonna be right for you guys that's the
biggest thing they match it to you it
comes right to your door shipped for
free you don't ever have to go to the
mattress store again um they've also
been uh awarded number one best overall
mattress pick by of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine what i ain't talking highlights
i'm talking gq and why oh man uh so just
go to helixsleep.com garbage uh take the
two minute quiz they'll match you with
the customized mattress you'll get the
best sleep of your life uh they have a
10-year warranty and you'll get to try
it out for free forget this for a
hundred nights risk-free you'll get to
try it out for a hundred nights risk
free they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but i'm telling you
you will i got mine and it's it's a game
changer um so here we go helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep.com garbage
that's helixsleep.com
garbage for up to 200 off and two free
pillows wow do it raycon raycon raycon
[Music]
i'm a fan i'm a client i wear them all
the time now that i'm back out there
mixing and mingle with people i don't
want to get caught up in the drama
what's going on in the streets yeah i
want to have my own vibe my own playlist
rocking and rolling keeping it moving
and the raycon wireless earbud is
absolutely fantastic i resisted earbuds
for such a long for years i don't i
don't like the other ones that slip and
they're sticking down these are
unbelievable they fit perfectly in your
ear they're comfortable the volume's
fantastic love them yeah also too i
don't know about you now that this is
new to you when you're running around
the city or walking or doing whatever
don't you i feel like i'm in a movie or
i'm in the soundtrack or
i'm i'm more focused i'm not getting
caught up but oh
this that the other thing you feel great
it's it's fantastic uh raycon's has a
32-hour battery life so you can listen
to what you want when you want for a
really long time and get this crazy they
started half the price of other premium
audio brains which is officially bonkers
hahaha but i got to tell you this they
sound just as good half the price just
as good what are we doing no brainer get
on them sign yourself up and raycons
comes with a 45 45-day happiness
guarantee so you can't lose give them a
try you'll see what we mean yeah um so
right now
our listeners avari garbage can get 15
off the raycon order at buy raycon.com
garbage one more time get a pen get a
pencil whatever you need that's by
raycon dot com slash garbage say 15 on
raycon i'll even do it one more time for
you buy raycon.com garbage do it folks
this podcast is sponsored by our good
friends that better help yes let me ask
you a question gang are you losing it
are you talking to yourself are you
going absolutely broncos pulling your
hair out can't deal we're about two
years into this pandemic i'm done are
you emotional eating are you do you got
anxiety because i have all those things
creeping up on me and the good people
that better help actually can help yes
it's not a crisis hotline it's not a
self-help hotline it's actual licensed
therapist in the privacy of your own
home that you can get matched up within
48 hours yeah guys uh if you if you
haven't done talk therapy before it's
give it a shot this is an easy way in
it's the easy way into the pool you know
what i mean you're trying to do it from
home there's no like getting in the car
meeting this guy talking to him his
office smells weird yeah you can hear
the neighbors talking the waiting room
you don't have to deal with any of that
this is easy peasy services available
worldwide for international listeners
also to have the broad range of
expertise available that might not be
available locally if you live in the
middle of like you know
you know [ __ ] oklahoma you can't
get somebody like that you gotta get you
can get a specialist yeah
um there's probably one guy in town and
he does horses too
so you can log into your account at any
time send a message to your counselor
you'll get a timely thoughtful response
and schedule weekly video calls or phone
calls whatever's easier for you
um and better help want you to start
living a happier healthier life today
yeah don't wait uh so go to uh
betterhealth.com garbage that's
betterhelp h-e-l-p and join over one
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional i know when i
started talk when i started doing
therapy it's a game changer it just
gives you another set of eyes on the
problem someone goes hey have you
thought about it this way have you
thought about it that way and you go oh
shh because you're living in your head
you don't know what to happen in the
outside world oh yeah then someone looks
in and goes yo you're bonkos i've been
there brother stop this do this look
think about it this way you go oh [ __ ]
you're right so give it a shot if you
haven't if you're on the fence this is
an easy way in to do it special offer
for ayg listeners you get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com garbage
one more time that's betterhelp.com
garbage now back to the show but now i
got health insurance like we are good
and i had a fork for a while i would do
a thing where i would take my sock my
feet sock off stand on a rug and then do
a spin like a spin and it would just
burn like
and it would just like take off should i
not be too shy no no judging by the
faces in the room i will move on
no it's not it's beautiful
yeah but it's also you're so you've told
it you've done the spit i don't know the
spin it caught me off guard a little bit
you're so numb that's the first time i'm
hearing you're like yeah we do this cool
spin i'm like i don't know how cool it
is you got mad dude a day when i was i
was rubbing my feet in your car
on the on the oh that's so good oh
people catch you took my flip-flops off
flip-flops off brand new car he's in my
brand new car
and he's got his [ __ ] hoofs
and he's just mashing them together and
i'm like socks on is one thing i'm like
whatever that carpet is it was like a mr
scrunchy it was [ __ ] perfect yeah
let me try this thing
in the trunk
what did cassidy say that killed us he
was like stop rubbing your snout
he sneezed and then and he didn't you
know he sneezes like it's like he smith
it's like that scene in the mask when he
swallows the bomb like it's like
it's so aggressive
i disagree
and then yeah tommy goes can you use
your hoof to cover your snout next time
pig jokes mom pick jokes
you believe this he's a good kid uh he's
a good kid you're a good kid huh you're
a good kid i like you boys all right
this next this next one's uh from snake
with arms did your parents save your
baby teeth
no i don't think
my mom is uh minded for sure but she
was your nurse so any of that [ __ ] she's
like
[Music]
you know not wrapping up the toe yeah no
i don't think they can baby that's gross
yeah we kept i found them in like a
dresser or something as
i grew up i was like what you never once
oh man i'm sorry you never want to look
bet like i keep things that you want to
look back you go like oh i had a snapple
bottle i kept from the first time i ever
kissed a girl i kept it in a box
her essence was in there
how long it was in eighth grade
until i finished a jab my mom threw it
all out but uh that was like oh this is
what a snapple looked like in eighth
grade it had the old design it was
fantastical it brings you back little
nostalgia what nostalgia do you get from
teeth or fingernail clippings or
whatever weird [ __ ] that people are
keeping i always thought [ __ ] it was
weird and i remember as a little kid
looking at it and be like what the [ __ ]
does this mean is when they would bronze
your little baby shoes when you were a
kid i thought they did that when people
died no my mom
everybody had [ __ ] bronze shoes and
i'd be like what the [ __ ] they were just
hedging their bets
[Laughter]
they're not all going to make it you'll
get a good deal now
you get them in bulk someone's bound to
croak that and the little ceramic hand
things are always weird too my mom has
those up what's the ceramic you know
when you're a little kid you make a
little imprint and you bring it home and
your parents keep it oh right we did
that when yours probably got shattered
on a kitchen wall
like you think my parents were together
that's great
have you used the family what's up
yeah
um
no when we got when we got our in-ground
pool we did it
like uh
that's cool though yeah what do you mean
in-ground pool they poured the pool we
like did our hands in the car little
brother did his foot and it was like you
know
1991 or whatever watching i'm so i'm i'm
actually surprised that your mom partook
in that that's bananas it was also
saving your teeth i don't think it
wasn't like she didn't like pull them
out at night and look at them i don't
think it was again she must have meant
that she forgot they were
and it was it was it was in a dresser
that was it in like a little like like a
little like a little bag that like mints
would come in at a wedding like
something like that you know what i'm
talking about what if yes like that
jordan almonds oh you like the like a
little sheer bag or whatever
that was made out of her panties all
right she doesn't listen to them you
don't look at the teeth and go oh i miss
these teeth i remember when he had these
teeth i know but i think it was one of
those things
i mean first of all there wasn't like 50
of them i think it was like one for and
i
i think they took it and then it's one
of those things and i kind of have it
now where i'm like oh i don't want to
show this brian
there's a hundred teeth in there
she's got around her neck like a witch
doctor how many wisdom teeth do this kid
have the only time i'm doing that is
going i'm gonna frame him for a murder
i gotta sprinkle these around in case we
ever need to act like we're dead
throw your baby teeth in some burning
yacht
yeah just to get out of a couple irs
bills
oh god apparently kevin said he hasn't
been in the dentist in
this guy's stolen his baby
two facts he's dead and he never grew
out of his baby i just did the same joke
you did i just repeated it
this whole show is copy and paste it
baby
[Laughter]
i will say i'm upset i did have a plan
that i [ __ ] up i was going to bring a
little framed picture of me and sneak it
out oh we would have loved it but i
didn't want to tell anybody until like a
year later oh dude we want to [ __ ]
like
one of the ideas we had is we wanted to
print out uh
for when each guest got here we would
have we would go back and find a baby
picture of them or like a picture as a
kid and have it but we just don't know
it seems a little it's intrusive yeah
but also be like oh here i'll show you
this
i'm gonna show you stop the podcast i'll
show you a picture i also have to look
it up so it's gonna be a while
all right i'll get back in a couple of
you as a baby no me as a kid
while you do that i realized the other
day that i have the the transcripts from
all the clips for all the subtitles and
we could put it into like an ai program
and have it generate like an ai version
of what it thinks in ru garbage that's
amazing oh that's pretty good yeah wait
we have all the
what holy [ __ ] great greg which was just
that doesn't look like you at all yeah
bowl cut glasses also had sex in eighth
grade so this guy was getting laid i
don't think that is wild that's 100
percent amazing even says corluza what
the [ __ ] carluzzo
what do you think kippy
that does not have i mean i i don't
think it looks like him but i don't
think that looks like the boy that
you're impersonating 15 years i have his
teeth
that kid died in a kid died in a car
fire in 91. i tricked his mom huh
remember these hunts me
you spit them out of your mouth put them
back in
oh man oh man good times
this is a warm-up
ah this is from chris you or anyone in
your family ever cut sweatpants into
sweatshorts
what my dad was big on sweatshirts of
course i think the 80s and 90s were that
was like everything got cut down to a
certain point yeah 100 percent yeah long
sleeve became short sleeve
short sleeve became no sleeve yeah
[ __ ] that was big street clothes
became [ __ ] sleep clothes always
you'd cut the shirt you cut the sleeves
off the shirt to short sleeve then it
would become this and then it would
become a rag to clean the threads
we were big on t-shirt you know it was
weird back in the day it didn't become
comfortable or cool looking until you
had it for like a year or two yeah you
know what i mean when the t-shirt wore
in perfectly yeah now they make them
like that to distress jeans and all that
stuff but back in the day you got to put
[ __ ] work into that you know how they
do those distressed jeans no they give
them there's
there's a small town in africa that gets
all of the clothes first and they wear
everything for like two years and then
they take them
for sure
and uh so there's just one city
i just met this there's one city where
all these really poor people are wearing
very high clothes
everybody's got lucky's on
i love a good lie
anyway i had i uh you had you cracked
illiterate
yeah
um all right this one's from hunter
first question your dog ever have worms
i thought every dog came with worms
i knew the first step was getting the
worms out is that a thing i think
yeah you do worm them i don't think
i don't think we ever i don't think
our dog's ever had worms 100
scratching the butt on the carpet oh
yeah that's worth that's a dead sign a
worm that's a sign of worms yeah well
then hey sorry rust
rusty had worms for most of the 2000 my
one buddies dog
[Laughter]
yeah my one buddies dog had it so bad
that you could actually see them you see
them coming out of the bus
look at how good that feels though
imagine dragging your [ __ ] butthole
directly on a nice carpet
oh it's got to be like shooting heroin
dude there's nothing better than that
i'm not allowed back at the ramada
nothing better than a good butt itch
and then you go what then you look at
your hand you go what have i done
what am i done
i feel like a surgeon walking to this
point
cindy hold on my calls
push my 330.
push my 330 and get the iodine
i'm gonna need a new pair of drawers too
these things are a little ripe oh man
you know the podcast is going right i
keep looking for toby heaps going that's
the clip
i thought that is the clip
that's the card i just love a producer
in the back that's going that's the clip
boys kid never stops working
smoking a cigar
joke's on you i'm editing the clip from
last week
yeah
everybody loved the wildwood video
they're like oh you're not paying toby
enough i'm like toby is handsomely
conscious excited for his work
um all right back to school we did a
little we did a back to school thing on
the patreon but love it by the way i'm
sorry to meet her up sure this morning
the performance the storm has gone
through a little bit cooler this morning
it felt it felt like the first sunny
[ __ ] come on the heat was gone though
yeah
the only thing that was different was i
wasn't sleeping in my sneakers
that was uh did you do that yeah i mean
i thought you i was gonna land
and you realized oh i'm crazy uh new
school clothes september i would sleep i
was so excited for school that i would
put the new clothes on and go to bed in
them and i would sleep in my new
sneakers and then the next time i wake
up ready for school that was so exciting
i thought you guys have done this i
thought people would do that though
and you were having sex in eighth grade
you expect me to believe that yeah
looking that good in bed anyone willing
to [ __ ] that's true
this guy's wearing pumps decided
to jump his bones your mom didn't say
anything no she said don't do that
okay i'll put my pajamas on and then i
would take them off and i would put the
school clothes back on and go lay down
and at some point would you have your
book bag on too
yeah that's why i have such bad
scoliosis from sleeping on my back like
this through the sheets you see his
shoes lighting up
holy [ __ ]
that's wild it's the best when you say a
thing when you're like oh there's a
thing we all did and everyone in the
room goes what that's that's what we're
finding out this show is people are like
oh yeah that and you're like no dude
sleeping in your clothes but there's i'm
guaranteeing there's going to be 50
comments on youtube being like oh i
slept with my [ __ ] shoes
you had to look like [ __ ] you slept in
your clothes everything's wrinkly my
hair was crazy all pulled out i looked
like a woman who just [ __ ] a guy all
night the next day
it was last year forget to wear them
yeah i had a giraffe it said a shirt
it's a jp for jurassic park and i was so
excited to wear it i slept in it
and now usually my shoes would come off
most of the night because you can't
really sleep the whole night in shoes
but i would i would dress up for school
i'm so excited and then i'd jump in bed
and then be ready for school in 30
seconds
i wake up like ready to go and my mom
was like well yeah the bus doesn't come
for 45 minutes relax yeah bought some
cartoons or something yeah
oh that's [ __ ] bonkers that's funny
um all right this one's from brad what
was the size of your crayon pack for the
school year
because this this was big did you just
get like the eight piece there was like
the the eight pieces what they would
give out at like the
like in a restaurant if you sat down to
like do the do the crossword puzzles i'd
give you that little like eight piece
now it's a four pack and they don't give
a [ __ ] what you do with it back in the
day you had to give that [ __ ] back yeah
and you usually got a raw deal on that
broken ones [ __ ] up ones you're
missing a color
now it's [ __ ]
well there was like the 16 maybe the big
guy was the 64.64
i had that one year but that was like
this this is lasting for a decade this
has to get you out of elementary school
dude we had a kid who was so he was
clearly poor his mom worked at the rose
art factory rose art was yeah yeah that
was like a crayon yeah
everyone made fun of him every day
except the first day of school when he
would show up i'm not flying like
crayola you have like colored pencils
crazy they used to make those things
that would be giving them the people he
would like he had deals he'd be like
yeah man like you watch my back for the
year yeah i'll give you a 64 rosary
because his mom would just jam him with
free supplies get all the best supplies
and they still made fun of him oh they
sucked yeah
he wore the full white suit on picture
day before
what is this communion what the [ __ ] did
with sneakers everyone else was like oh
we have ripped shirts on he was like no
my mom makes me go all the way on
picture day uh she's got that rosar
money
he's laughing all the way to the bank i
had it i remember it was like a flat it
was i had the big 64 guy
and they had colors you didn't even know
that was like you were learning about
colors they were dropping new ones every
season too once once crayola got hip to
what they had in their hands they really
put the [ __ ] foots on the throats
they started pumping out everything we
had to do like a building landscape type
thing like a city you know what i mean
like oh these tall buildings or whatever
and everybody everybody else had their
like four crayons they were trying to
make yours looks like inception
dude buildings coming in on each other
and i remember the one kid going uh mrs
you know whatever jaminsky what should
we use for the for the for the brick it
was like second grade and i had a brick
ran and i pulled everybody else was
using brown and wrong i pulled out brick
red and was like oh yeah
[ __ ] did my [ __ ] up real tight
that was great she doesn't usually give
out a pluses
but you earned it that way oh for sure i
don't care who you are how old you are
you sit down with the fresh sheet of
[ __ ] paper and you crack open a box
of crayons
clean living also how do you say the
word yeah i just picked that up too not
like that what
i don't know how to make crayons crayons
crayons how do you say it all right i
went to the store and i bought some
crayons crayons crayons that's
that is the the right way to say it
is wrong
i say crowns crowds yeah
i'll set my growing up it was crowns my
dad would be like get your crowns crowns
that's crazy
this is not trying to try to
[Laughter]
it was either crayon people would say
crayon or crowns it's crayons yeah
crayons crayons that's euro trash [ __ ]
get the euro yeah
it's made in pennsylvania isn't it the
crayola i'm saying the same that's how
the europeans would sense
it's crayon it's crayon crayola crayola
whereas did roseart also make her is
crayon the thing or is it like a kleenex
type thing you're right yeah
a crayon is the item is the instrument
yeah it's the instrument i think it
might be crayola
crayola is the company but i think they
might have came up with crayon
like i don't know didn't i think roseart
makes crayons they think they do and it
would say
a pencil or stick of colored chalk or
wax used for drawing yeah there we go
yeah crayoff that's stupid i'm gonna
kill myself for that one
wait it's saying under the pronunciation
crown
if you're a [ __ ] idiot
i don't know if that's
well there's no talking about that there
goes your bonus
uh
yeah i know it says only smart guy say
crown
i knew it totally crayon send me that
link will you crayon is like tomato
tomato yeah or bran
someone ever came to me can we mark this
on your schedule i would take both hands
and wrap them around the neck until
their life ceased but it was a nice
little british lady oh i'd kiss her
first
into heaven you go plant one horn
i'd be a little more before i take her
life where you're going you're not gonna
need schedules
it's not
crayon is wrong on all accounts so i'm
not saying crown's right crown is wrong
it's crayon crayon is one person 100
wrong okay
i choose a way to roll over and die on
that one
greg do you say aunt or aunt oh my aunt
marianne aunt mary
yeah an aunt marianne i haven't had
marianne and my god she does she wears
more like how are you saying that more
elaborate than you've ever seen
she might as well bail ever she dresses
like craven i don't know if you're
familiar with the man who tries to hunt
spider-man so that is how my aunt
dresses all the time i'm sorry i stepped
on it did you i did i screamed it i
screamed into the microphone they'll
hear it this is this is a big one we're
in aunt we're in aunt hoodies yeah which
is named after brian six's aunt do you
have any i don't know when you did this
she did the show very early on we were
still via zoom
uh i was down the shore yeah it was
still very early on in the pandemic of
in the life of the show do you have any
aunts
or uncles that you don't refer to by
their first name for example aunt tooty
i have an aunt soupy and quinny
no no i just have an aunt marianne and
aunt karen i have an aunt linda who's
not an aunt she's some quite a weird
cousin thing that happened we can't
do this she's an aunt just call her
auntie yeah cause that's whatever yeah
yeah of course yeah no i don't have like
an aunt dippy you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah grease ball
i do have uncles though but that's
because they were in the mob you know i
had like an uncle lefty really um we've
never met he died he had uh i don't know
if he had a right he was missing in hand
he used to stick shift so he had a left
hand that he could hold the steering
wheel missing a right hand but would put
his nub in the steering wheel and then
shift with the left hand he drove lefty
yes
yeah yeah he earned that one huh yeah
yeah he did yeah
he's died in a car wreck so
i don't know i
got hit by a drunk driver turns out you
can't drive like that for a long period
of time without being dead
flaming we found his teeth
baby teeth though apparently it was only
18 months
[Laughter]
um
yeah
um all right this one's just a
no-brainer this is from corey ever take
the cellophane from your sig pack to use
it as a vessel for weed or drugs and
then seal it with a lighter that's a
real derby
like the cellophane from a cigarette
pack you pull off the plastic you put
wheat in there and then seal it i don't
smoke because i'm better than you guys
no i don't know this is in high school
yeah we're not we're not picking up bags
and sick packs now we're gentlemen
the big thing was like yeah i don't have
a bag and i was like oh here i have sigs
and you would take the cellophane off
like the plastic square right and then
you drop it in there and seal it up real
trashy somebody's selling you that to
you too oh yeah off the jump is [ __ ]
trash yeah i remember the first time i
bought we had about a handful like the
guy was just like oh i don't have a bag
do you have cigs i'm like no he's like
all right here man and i just had to
like run back to the car with like a
[ __ ] eighth in my hand
this is a weird thing i don't know what
they're doing right now they should
bring back candy cigarettes as edibles
they should make edibles out of the old
school candy cigarettes that's like a
fun way to do candy cigarette and now
you take a little nibble
it's not a bad idea even the edible gum
i i i like that they don't have that
they have to right you think i mean they
have edible everything yeah yeah candy
cigarettes edible headphones
things just come out
no real rule rhyme or reason
[Music]
all right this one's nuts this is this
is crazy
take this happens in a car right so this
question happens in a car ever cool down
hot food by holding it out the window or
up to the ac vent so you can eat it more
comfortably i would say that i've done
this not in a car i've done this with my
air conditioner with uh there's like
some food that was too hot you just turn
the pasta a little towards the air
conditioner cool it down a little bit
because it's speed food is about eating
it fast i'll do it i'll do you one more
than that if yeah i make you know take a
stouffer's french bread or some sort of
frozen pizza if i make the pizza i throw
it in the freezer for like 45 cents yes
100 take that edge off the top
the invention i tried to get pushed for
a while was the cold stove it was a
stove oh it immediately cooled something
that was like it's the opposite of a
microwave sometimes your food's too hot
you put it in the cold stove chill it
down it should do that for liquid i mean
they they do have the technology i just
don't think it's uh no one wants to buy
it imagine just make pouring like a warm
bottle of soda or a beer into a thing
and it comes out cool
clearly none of you guys watched shopped
where the blast chiller
is the hottest commodity out i know but
it doesn't always work and you need a
lot of time you know if you do know
chopped if you do go to the blast
chiller you're [ __ ] rolling the dice
that's the biggest risk you can take is
the blast children i'm thinking the greg
stone cold stove
that's what we're looking at that's the
infomercial right there
greg stone cold stove
cold stove
creamery no i would call it cold stone
greg stone's cold stone cold cold stone
yeah greg's cold stone yeah i can't call
i'm sorry i'm just upset that this
whoever this this chop show clearly
listens to my podcast you know it's just
another idea
clearly listens to my podcast like all
the producers around it's friday night
we gotta watch it we gotta watch greg
yeah well that's how they got the hot
blast cold machine whatever you're
talking about goddamn rachel ray i'd
warn you she got me
dear pig you took my idea and i would
like some money greg
you know who the inventor of the cold
stuff
all rights reserve
holy [ __ ] that's funny yeah you gotta
eat it quick in the car i don't know
what you're having in the car that's too
hot though if you're a slice of pizza
dude
[ __ ] hot slices ah i know but i'm not
eating pizza in the car if i'm to get
pizza you got to go in and get pizza
place you can grab a dollar slice
you pull up you pull up but if somebody
runs in grabs a couple dollar slices and
you know where you get hemmed up if
they're pulling it right out of the oven
and it's nuclear sure i understand that
and you got to [ __ ] put in front of
the ac vents to me that's still like oh
we'll double park it's gonna take 90
seconds to eat this pizza let's get out
and eat the pizza yeah i only ever eat
ribs when i'm driving anyway so
i don't know why i wouldn't need to cool
them down more of a risotto man
i degrease up the wheel a little so i
can't turn when there's a child in the
way oh that's funny i always remember
doing that with mac and cheese when i
was a kid and we would take we would
[ __ ] it would be burning hot my mom
gave it to us take it and [ __ ] hold
it in front of the vent for like a good
minute yeah so like the the first inch
is like ice cold yeah so then you use
that as a balance with the molten center
one hot one
yeah throw on knight rider and [ __ ]
call me later i wanted to invent a
syringe of ice kind of thing that you
could push into like a hot pocket when
it's too hot in the middle dark brown
i'm always trying to invent things that
can make me eat my food fast yeah it's
all here you have to wait dude i got a
good one
edible tape don't talk to me because
right now you clearly some of the rad
dude cast
edible tape was invented on the rad dude
cast for burrito fixins that's exactly
what i came up with in high school i got
i got witnesses yeah i don't care you
got witnesses because they clearly kind
of future
to watch my podcast what and to go back
are you talking about taping up the
burrito yeah any kind of food tape for
tacos burritos pizza and then you have
different flavor tapes yes stays closed
yes and not just bubblegum flavor we're
talking sauce flavored you got sauce
flavored tape for when your spaghetti
breaks i've been singing this tune for
years yeah he's been singing
my podcast it's okay it's okay it's all
right everyone wraps me up you and that
pig rachel ray
yes edible tape is the move wait but
what's the spaghetti tape what are you
taping for my spaghetti breaks like as
they're upset i'd like to to tape my
spaghetti but it was just a dumbbell
okay i was like no i was i was more
genuine i was more curious
it was a dumb riff no it was fantastic
riff don't eat on the riff no hate that
stupid pig rachel ray everybody keep it
big anyway
um all right let's see that when his
spaghetti rips
oh look at me or my spaghetti can
someone fix my
meatballs mom's
broken that's the commercial
uh
it's not a bad idea
what the tape it is a good idea the
burrito the burrito taco yeah give it a
give it a wrap and then you don't have
to worry about it it's more it's yeah
it's way easier it
to be honest with you and i'm saying
this with a long long track record
figured out the show on nickelodeon from
the 90s 1999 edible taco tape segment i
recorded the podcast in 1998 so
clearly
clearly uh the liberal media stealing
from it that pig alex summers took my
idea mr stone are you familiar with the
channel nickelodeon jr
no senator i am not i miss a stone have
you ever been slammed before
no senator nobody's known anybody the
only answer to have you been slimed is i
don't know
that's how you get slimed
reference
i went over my head yeah sort of the
slime
there you go all right he brings this
full circle
just cause it's a bad riff doesn't mean
you shouldn't bring it back
buddy i'm all on board with it
that was a hard break right there
i feel like lefty was driving
drop [ __ ] drop the clutch real quick
uh
it's a wonky one this is so [ __ ] and
valleys in this thing this is no it's
also i feel like we're all on shrooms
we've been running at 107 miles an hour
so when it gets below 90 we all panic
we're like well now we're dead
it's like that's like speed podcasting
plus i got a couple of stinkers in that
are weighing on my mind
no and now we're
here yeah you gotta have it this one's
just bananas if you're not doing this i
don't know what the [ __ ] going on this
is from dan c haven't had a question
right have you ever used toilet paper as
tissues or tissues at toilet as toilet
paper that's just that's like what you
do common use right yeah if you get
jammed up i i that's insane issues is
toilet paper yeah if you're fi if you
don't have toilet that's more important
if you don't be a tough look for me they
don't go well you're the exception
i mean listen i like a good tissue as
much as the next guy but they don't got
the moxie for [ __ ] well no one's
saying that kind of warfare you shower
afterwards
yeah yeah so that's what i'm saying what
do you mean
it would never be an option if i had
tissues right yeah that's what i'm using
of course i'm not gonna yeah if i was
jammed up somewhere that's what we're
saying yeah i'm not saying do you prefer
them oh okay it's in a situation
have you ever done it yet what's the
number three thing you go for so it's
toilet paper paper towel shoes
i go right to paper towel if i don't
have it because it's cheap
after that is a is a fast food napkin
yes a fast food restaurant napkin will
save your life yeah
[Laughter]
this one's from clark do you or anyone
in your family ever drive a saturn
let me tell you this right now
i feel like you were a big high school
saturn kid it did not have a saturn but
saturns were such good i stand behind
saturn you definitely listen to weezer
in a saturn before in a parking lot
somewhere can we pause real quick can i
do a quick aside
i get into an uber once guy clear
doesn't speak english the first track of
the blue album of the weezer album is
playing and i went sir
did you put this on for me and he went
yes and it always works
he saw me when this guy likes weezer put
weezer on in the uber completely
i guess racist i don't know what that is
but nailed it like of course i'll listen
to the [ __ ] blue album you gotta give
that guy a hefty tip too no i ran out of
the cabin before i jump out before he
gets to the spot so he can't chase me um
before you're there
what was the original question though i
kind of forgot i lived uh drive at
saturn drive a saturday saturn's are
such good cars look on the road if you
you can still find siders on the road
that they were so good it put them out
of business that's what someone told me
about because hey there was no turnover
there's no turnover they also weren't
doing commission you buy a saturn their
employees were like eight bucks an hour
you know what i mean whatever much they
were making back in the day yeah like
they were a great car company that gets
[ __ ] on a lot damn because they were
doing it right because they were doing
around i remember they were
early 90s and then they kind of got corn
they were like real pointy the saturns
and stuff they kind of look like the
pontiacs and stuff like the sunfires
and then in the early 2000s they came
out with that ion and that was a game
that saturn eye on was like a cool
looking car they leaned heavy into the
[ __ ] automatic seat belt though that
we talked about a couple years ago
every single teacher had one of those
things yeah check it out
[Laughter]
see in science class yeah saturns were
too futuristic when they came out i i
even the names of the ion i'm like i
don't we are not an ion family
we're pipe fitters give me a chevy a
board
we can't be driving something called a
[ __ ] eye on it i need something with
some numbers in it yeah give me 28.
f250 something yeah but i did not own a
saturn dude girls with big puffy pink
dc's always drove the saturn eclipse
yeah there was the big set no mitsubishi
mitsubishi eclipse yeah also known as
the stripper wagon yes i've never seen a
stripper not an
eclipse man a white one my sister had
one and she was not a stripper what my
sister had one and she was not a
stripper i love you sarah
she's a good girl she's fair
uh how'd she get that
birthday present sweet 16 or something
no it wasn't her first car it was like
uh i think she had just graduated from
college i think like my
dad helped her out with it at some point
yeah that's real trashy yeah your dad
helps you buy an eclipse it was like the
down payment he might have made that she
was responsible for the payment i forget
that was when there was a little bit of
cash floating around
things went belly up after that eclipse
that was the heyday
we saw it coming he was like i know what
your job is going to have to be when we
lose all our time
i'll get you the eclipse mitsubishi
eclipse the most repo
car
you're making that up 100 that makes
sense i wanted to be cool like stone
can i have you at all no toby oh really
adobe's check now i still believe that's
true
i find out what the most repo card is
it's probably
hyundai's tobias
bmw i would think because someone who
can't afford whatever there's not that
many of them you gotta i'm thinking
a lot of like the honda honda civic is
the most stolen car just because there's
the sheer volume right there's millions
i thought it used to be the integra
remember the accurate integra if you
were [ __ ] poor that was the rich
man's boy that or a prelude remember
that oh the praise was it a honda
prelude they were yeah that guy if some
guy pulled up in a honda prelude he
would buy you sigs if you were on yeah
i'd rather have an accurate accuracy
sure that's a little bit higher level oh
you know fancy dancy lemon pants that's
still to me is i'm like accurate all the
all the rich girls had acuras in high
school yeah like it was like their dads
were like lawyers or doctors or
something they all had the same action
yeah you were legend they had uh it was
the tsx you know it was a sign of wealth
though not rich but wealth when somebody
was rolling around in like a late model
volvo wagon and somebody had one of
those yeah you knew that their parents
were like old money because it was
understated it wasn't fancy it was so
expensive there's a lot of value in this
yes we're gonna get it and we're gonna
get a hundred years out of this thing
yeah yeah my boy my boy rolled around
for a little bit in one of those or a
sob too sorry oh yeah yeah 100 sobs were
hot for a minute do you know where the
phrase saab story came from because the
ki it was like original thing of people
all wanted bmws and then they would get
sobs instead and they'd be like oh i'm
sad about it like well that's a saab
story that's where that there's no way
that's true
it's not even funny enough
for the lie
[Music]
they're a swedish aerospace company
that's been around for like 150 years
yeah jimmy didn't get a sob so he
started crying
i said hey that's a real sob story
this is going to take over they've been
making fighter jets since the 40s
[Laughter]
stone son of a [ __ ]
we're onto stone now they came up with
rolls royce right my buddy royce one day
he was at the drive-through i said hey
you're rolling over there huh
he fell down a bunch of stairs and they
said here comes rolls royce and then the
car guy
uh all right here let's see we got a
couple more here uh we got murdock uh
who what were you
murdoch what were you carrying your
lunch into school lunch box with a
thermos brown bag grocery grocery bag or
were you buying lunch kind of guy greg
uh high school i was buying lunch yeah
yeah that's the luck yeah
and the older you get you can't be
taking a lot of stuff to school with you
but also the parents that cared about
their kids made them lunch yeah a 1.45
is easier for a mom who's just being
like just getting hung over yeah here
you go
five bucks this is for the week yeah and
you'd blow it the first day oh
the iced teas yeah yeah yeah yeah just
like a king five dollars in the
lunchroom when you were a kid people
would kneel to you
but then when you're down you feel like
a real loser yeah that's how you feel
when you're scrounging yeah when you're
down on the bottom of the slots in the
casino come thursday you got no lunch
money you're trolling around trying to
collect and stuff like that that's what
i always say
be the guy when you have the five
dollars you be the guy who's also the
friday guy with no money i'll never be
able to think like that when friday
comes around you're gonna talk you need
to talk to those people you stepped on
their necks when you had five yeah now
they got to give you their fries you
dirt ball on monday get out of my way
yeah you know greg you're really
shooting your mouth off on tuesday and
now you're coming to me your hat in your
hand
wanting the chocolatey clear i don't
know man
yeah sometimes you have to wait i don't
know if you guys do this but if you
didn't have lunch money they'd put you
at the back of the line and whatever was
left they would give you
or
[Laughter]
yeah or they would give you this like
government peanut butter and jellies
there was like no frills you would get
the big old bar you go here's your
peanut butter and jelly this was free
you could eat this if you didn't have
your lunch money jesus yeah rice i don't
know if our school did that
mine didn't i know that much
i mean i like to think they would have
fed us regardless oh yeah but that's
funny they got to humiliate you like
that they can't just slide to your
[ __ ]
plane hey go wait in this cage till we
find out what we have left here i got a
little apple crisp for you don't tell
nobody i gave it to you all right there
were some days my dad would drive over
there like it's a russian witness box
[ __ ] they're looking up through the
glass
jesus did you have to do that a couple
of times oh so many times because uh
you'd have to do lunch tickets in
grammar school and i would do they came
to you for the month and i would lose
them yeah the first day yeah and so i'd
have to be like all my lunch tickets are
gone they're like well then you have to
wait the end of the line and there's
leftover food you get that and i was a
leftover food guy i would hang out with
the lunch lady and be like ah man uh
maybe put a little something aside for
me that's a good piece
yeah yeah i like the corner slice that
thing yeah you're picking up slices of
sicilian i remember telling the lady
they're telling me being like here's all
my lunch tickets for the month can you
just have them now and then just let me
claim them and let me come later and
they were like no this is you
negotiating with the lunch ladies 90
year old woman who wouldn't budge man
you must he must have been a weird kid
you saw the picture i was your mom
wouldn't ration them out to you every
day no the one he had ours in an
envelope they would give me an envelope
but then everyone home that would like
stay in my desk and then i would lose
them in a desk and they needed to clean
your desk at the end of the back of that
side
we were talking about the other day that
thing would eat things yeah you were
like what the [ __ ] going on back there
but when you would clean it oh the dream
boy in there oh yeah i remember being
like i can reach to the back of it i
feel like if you could get to the back
of it
i feel like a ceo sitting in there with
a clean desk did you guys
did you guys have the desk with the
convertible top or just the hole hole
because we just had the hole a couple
times i died
best of both worlds it was nice i can't
tell you which one i like better
probably the pull-up it was pretty
classy i don't know what kind of temper
temper boys you are but uh either of you
i flipped a couple of those desks in my
day at school i've definitely shut up
you don't say
cause we had those hard tile floors they
would [ __ ] yeah they would fly yeah
yeah there's chairs too yeah oh i would
just go i'm
[Music]
and
not
flip the thing and then if peter go like
all right now you got to clean it up and
uh you know you're after school hit you
with a blow down or ritalin
there he goes
all right i couldn't find the number one
most repossessed car for some reason the
statistic just like it looks like five
players didn't see it but i do have the
state with the most repossessed
questions oh that's pretty fun florida
yep
ohio
i'm gonna go is this per capita or total
uh
the highest rates of 30 day
delinquencies
ohio i'm gonna say new jersey because
one we're the most densely populated
also we have newark and also i'm from
there so i know the stuff
that might be pretty good
goose eggs all around mississippi
so i assume it's all burned out eye
rocks i don't know what's going on those
hillbillies don't know how to drive
[ __ ] screwed us
mississippi oh what the [ __ ] was that
you know why because there's been a
couple of stopping starts on this i
don't know what's going on
or what i could have given you something
but my mind went to we used to call
iraq's
something it was like italian
something there was a there was an
analogy for iraq the iraq's people who
drove iraq's we called them something
like and my mind went there so i was
there by cameron was like
yeah italians running on credit some
[ __ ] like that it was a real slur
that was fun yeah because the italians
used to drive the eye rocks
weren't i was i guess
yeah
i think it was a more an economic
disposition thing that it was
nationality yeah it was the most
expensive cheap car yeah yeah yeah yeah
and that's like a lower class people
think that's classy right like trashier
people are like that's also let me flex
in this thing wait till i get my eye
rock
then you're gonna [ __ ] believe in me
i still think it is the iroc is also the
worst camaro they made it was the
slowest also the only one that wasn't
stick so it was really like for the
poor people sure yeah it wasn't even the
good camaro yeah it was like the worst i
did a bunch of camaro research one day
for a joke and it never worked but now i
know everything about [ __ ] pony cars
when the transmission on an automatic
goes you look real trashy
driving around man
all right let's see here we'll do one or
two more and then we gotta run it's just
been a fun one
um this is a home run this is from jake
i haven't had one on the red on the air
yet and i love how they're abbreviating
h y o a i y f have you or anyone in your
family ever had a time share in a
non-beach town
my friend has one in branson missouri
that's a home [ __ ] run why what's
there branson missouri there's a lot of
theater in branson missouri not a bad
theater i presume that's where like uh
jacqueline schmiernoff is
and someone else yeah there's like a lot
of like dinner theater and stuff from
ransomware that's a tough look my friend
had one i don't know if this counts
because it was the poconos so like it
counts why you would do that but also
like so two things one i remember we
were hanging out and i saw a girl and i
just came back i was like oh i kissed
that girl my friends were like you did
let's go ask her
[Laughter]
i almost lost a tooth on this microphone
i don't think the insurance is made up
in here either i'm being so i'm being a
hunter hey you chip it you bought it
right now uh but we might also remember
them trying to be like i didn't know you
can get like a thing like in florida or
like the south jersey yeah wherever i
remember them trying to trade time
shares with other people and they were
like no
i don't want to go to the poconos it's
like a shitty game of monopoly
i don't want to go to lake harmony yeah
yeah i remember my family friend had one
growing up and i didn't get it we didn't
go on vacation i still don't get it we
would go down the shore i get it now
after i watch a documentary on it uh i
don't know who stays there with you how
do they get it how you get in there is
it always a condo no it's like you can
do hotels whatever uh now
since the
uh recession and like since the housing
bubble and everything burst
they there was a there's a documentary
of the guy the biggest guy that went
completely bankrupt
because he you own all these properties
and then no one can afford them or go
any more than you're like well i own 10
000 properties now yeah it's all based
on the fact that more money keeps coming
in um but you got the free trip to
disney world though
i never understood it because we our
vacations we went to the shore and we
went to myrtle uh or not myrtle we went
to ocean city maryland one summer like
every dirt bag family from philly we
said once you go once you go once when
you're like 12 that's it um so we went
down the shore all the time stinks or
you never went back next year did you
ever go to uh secrets we were just
talking about that too no no no no
because it's the c yeah
yeah for for the listeners it's like a
bar
not a res it's a bar on the water yeah
and you like can stand at a table and
drink in the water yeah yeah you could
eat your hot dogs in the water yeah a
lot a lot of eating hot dogs it's
encouraged yeah i hooked up with a girl
there
the way you said it i don't think it was
a girl
yeah oh she did a good job of making me
think um it was i guess her dick was
nice
it was very nice anyway um
yeah no never been that that's like the
big dirt bag thing when you turn 20 and
like failure 21 you're like we're going
to secrets for the weekend we got a
place yeah never went though
we should go
we should so the the one of the owners
weekended secrets one of the owners is a
listener really we called into his radio
show yeah remember yeah dude i won the
best times my life at secrets
want to do an ayg secrets [ __ ]
weekend yeah they'll have us
okay slash fng because i gotta use this
for mine too yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
cross promotion synergy
i can't be wasting content like that man
i got no
this is why you got to do it man you got
to seize the opportunity
get your name out there
but i'd love to do that for real we
don't even have to record it
as long as there's a buffet and i can
drink in a pool
let's do it
all right let's see let's do one more
this has been a topic uh as of recent is
it garbage to use diet pepsi as a mixing
with vodka
how do you feel about mixing anything my
my thing is if it's not a captain in
coke
you can go die it should be coke it
should be pepsi that could be a rum and
coke that's where you caught me pepsi is
for garbage people yes but i want to say
this i believe completely disagree
there's a resurgence of pepsi coming i
believe all the hipsters and all the
people are all it's going to be cool
yeah it's going to be cool
i think pepsi is going to hit a real
stride stride now because it's cool i'm
a mr pibb guy
through and through a [ __ ] gentleman
over but i'll kneel i'll kneel to pepsi
you'll bow down i'll bow down about that
i want its day to come i was in a bar
and somebody ordered like a whiskey and
mr pibb i believe
close up because trouble is coming yeah
yeah
yeah i think it can only be
i think if you order a yeah i'm mixing
vodka with soda isn't that that's not a
drink maybe like i thought when you're
13. i think maybe the question just
means diet soda right because nobody
hadn't no bars have pepsi in it always
it's always coke powder you're usually
something fake i got a shark
88d have you ever i mean brought this up
last time i may have have you ever heard
have you ever had a beverly
no beverly is a fountain soda that i
think they only serve at disney world
and it's like a [ __ ] coke but i love
the name because it's it's beverly yeah
yeah give me a beverly on the rocks
you said beverly soda brand i think so i
don't know where to get it except epcot
they probably only sell it there they
probably just make it for so some lady
beverly went hey i got one customer at
epcot think about how they think about
how much [ __ ] soda they move a day a
ton probably more than [ __ ] mr pip
does all year probably but i'm saying
like she never tried harder to get a
little bit out somewhere else i like how
you think it's a girl beverly it's
beverly it's the
you know who makes beverly who coca-cola
that's it
i gotta go back to inca cola
i gotta go
nothing wrong with any cola the golden
cola yeah [ __ ] i don't even know what
that is oh it's delicious their hometown
bloomfield where i'm from inca cola it's
the native american soda inca inca cola
it's like a golden cola it's a [ __ ]
top shelf ice cold where do you go and
it has a lot of cream soda vibes yes
very cream soda oh that stuff you've
seen it
you've seen it like a puyo puyo rico or
some place like those cans yeah they got
the rotisserie chicken and the green
sauce yeah wow i would never
never touch that
cocoa is better than multagoya that's
like i grew up with a lot of puerto
ricans and we were uh this is just like
a thing they all drank
malta goya can't do that or the uh or
the italian version of the the coffee
soda
coffee soda yeah the manhattan special
whatever it's called oh i've never had
this really yeah oh
interesting
second espresso cola
you would have had to come across it
growing up in the tri-state area they
probably in the 90s too young they're
probably like he's too young the bottle
looks like it had a little manhattan
scallion on it
i don't know that i've ever seen this
yeah you're on your own on this one big
man i guess i feel that way have you
ever had malta goya though it tastes
like sweet potatoes yeah it's disgusting
it tastes like sweet with the
consistency of blood all right that's it
yeah we're moving on it is
that's it
that's it
yeah
i like how you say we used to drink this
sweet potato cola that felt like blood
fun-loving guy
potato blood
dude people die for it not me though a
passion desire to make it come on
nothing on that
wrap it up we got to go gang that's the
episode stoney you've been absolutely
amazing
baby what do you got what do you want
the folks out there to know hit him oh
all right could you check out my podcast
call friday night greg friday night
energy on a wednesday morning that's the
catchphrase i love that by the way
that's great
and uh i got a new album out called uh
nike yes oh do you do you use sons of
[ __ ] i got an album uh out called uh
night cream the cream supreme that's on
all streaming services except youtube
music because [ __ ] them they got some
weird legal laws that we can't seem to
get through okay uh it's uh check out
that in uh my podcast right now greg
folks the kid plays it cool i don't know
what to tell you greg stone ladies and
gentlemen kippy what do you got for him
uh as always you know review subscribe
on itunes full video available you know
subscribe on youtube and then patreon
also guys live shows coming up we have
texas we have new york we have long
island we have new york city we're about
to announce we have philly get some
[ __ ] tickets also like the merch we
have uh koozies and a few card games
left oh yeah get them while they last
gang we love you and we'll see you next
week peace